welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and the biggest mystery from the
latest doctor streams in the multiverse
of madness trailer is the identity of
this glowing armored figure who battles
wanna maximuff in the multiversal
citadel that looks pretty familiar in
fact a lot like a certain museum in
london where i got a pamphlet about the
parthenon that they apparently colonized
that helped me understand killmonger's
anti-museum rant a lot better but
between this british museum set and what
we know about this mystery figure and
the illuminati nature of the people who
run this facility i have realized one
possibility that the more i think about
it actually makes more and more sense
and could connect this movie with
marvel's bigger plants with the events
ahead so i will pose to you the question
are the illuminati in the multiverse of
madness and the tva of the kang variant
he remains linked
before you say no and move on hear me
out and thanks to boxu for sponsoring
this video more on them later the story
for doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness was written by loki head writer
michael waldron collaborating with
director sam rainey and when it comes to
the multiversal aspects of this story
you can certainly sense the dna of the
loki series coursing through it both
stories are about mcu rule breakers who
violated the laws of reality in the
avengers affinity war endgame events who
are now dragged before a cryptic legal
authority who tower over the cuff
defendants each from a pompous deus
within an illustrious ethereal facility
lined with mysterious statues both
stories then enlist the defendant to
solve an apocalyptic threat that pits
them against a parallel female rule
breaker unfairly villainized for her
actions all while the hero has to deal
with infinite variants of himself i mean
even the dialogue is pretty similar the
variant we're hunting is
you the greatest threat
to our universe is you now you could
just cynically see this as marvel
recycling a formula that worked for them
on disney plus but i don't think michael
waldron a rick and morty writer who is
clearly pulling from that show's council
of rick's storyline i don't think the
guy would be that redundant for a marvel
film that came out within a year i also
don't think marvel studios would be that
obvious about it by accident either i
think these parallels between multiverse
and madness and loki are an intentional
clue for what this mcu illuminati really
is the multiversal rival and perhaps the
predecessor to kang's empire so let's
quickly take another look at that
mystery figure from the trailer every
close-up we can make out of this person
is that it is clearly a person of color
and based on a power set i have
theorized it could be photon from an
alternate reality where she is the
captain marvel equivalent either monica
rambo or her mother maria rambo now to
be clear in addition to that i strongly
suspect superior iron man is still gonna
factor into this story and might even
participate in this battle but you just
cannot tell me that this is the face of
tom cruise or whoever this movie cast as
an iron man variant and the alternate
shots in the online trailer in the tv
spot just don't look different enough to
tell me that this is not a person of
color however many online have begun to
make the case that this could actually
be jonathan majors or another actor
playing a younger nathaniel richards the
31st century engineer who becomes kang
the conqueror and whose younger form
suits up an advanced iron man tech to
become the young avenger iron lad now to
be honest i think this figure has more
pronounced hips more likely to be one of
the rambos but the vfx is still being
refined now whether you think this
figure's technology looks more
cree-derived or more stark-derived there
is an equal case to be made for both
figures to join the ranks of the
illuminati in this movie marvel's
illuminati is a secret alliance of
leaders from each corner of the marvel
world tony stark representing the
avengers and mankind charles xavier
representing mutant kind doctor strange
the sorcerers and the mystics reed
richards the fantastic four in the
scientific community black bolty and
humans which were cree genetic
experiments and neymar the people of
atlantis now this lineup in the movie
may very well just include past screen
versions of reed richards and black bolt
the way they cast patrick stewart to
return his professor x but if not there
is an opportunity here to give the seats
to another multiversal champion with
cree derived powers and another
scientist from the richards family line
nathaniel richards is reed richard's
descendant now while i am hunting for
these missable details i often find
myself in need of a little snack to keep
me moving forward well you can take your
snacking on an international adventure
with our friends at boxu baksu is a
monthly subscription service that
delivers premium japanese snacks and tea
pairings straight from japan to your
door baksu partners with family-owned
snack makers to make their original
treats the first boxer you get is called
seasons of japan and it lets you taste
the seasonal flavors popular in japan
every month after that you'll receive a
different themed box like this one it's
called spring ozer this is the first
time i've gotten this one so i'm super
excited to try them out you can see it
comes just stuffed with all these great
different snack options get these little
like rice krispies things i'm gonna try
one of these things
it looks like i don't know a little a
little chocolate thing
oh man
let me eat this whole thing it's like a
chocolate covered like
jelly middle
that's really good so let's find out
what that was each box comes with a
booklet that tells you about the
cultural theme and shares where all the
snacks come from that was a jelly
chocolate yubari melon the type of
cantaloupe that is grown in hokkaido
that's the northernmost island of japan
so if you want to get some unique
japanese snacks click the link in the
description and use our code rockstars
for 15 off your subscription orange
pipes thanks baksu
now in the breakdown i pointed out the
parallels between the citadel of the
illuminati and the citadel of he who
remains both run by men behind the
curtain using mechanized puppets to do
their bidding both structures have lit
towers and columns and four statues as
you walk into the central chamber and in
he who remains citadel one of those four
statues was destroyed one of the most
interesting production design details
that we still don't have an answer for
to me it suggested a past that he
remains still feels bitter over bitter
enough to not ever sweep that up now
while the illuminati citadel is smooth
and still intact perfect masonry he who
remains citadel is fractured inspired by
kintsugi pottery one seville aspiring to
perfection another citadel accepting
chaos picking up the pieces of that
previous failure now i know it seems
like i'm reaching here but some of y'all
say that for my theories that end up
being right so screw it there is 100 a
connection between professor x's
illuminati and multiverse of madness and
kang's tva in loki one of these
institutions inspire the other one of
these institutions is a response to the
other so i guess the question is which
came first the wicked or the gang i kind
of forced that now i made the case in
inside marvel that the illuminati's
reason for existing could be as a
defensive measure against the council of
kangs one altruistic multiversal
governing body to check the threat of a
self-serving imperial dynasty he who
remains backstory made it look like he
was the first scientist to discover
multiversal technology and to use it
cooperating with his variant selves now
while those variants end up going to war
with each other leaving he who remains
alone in his citadel he did warn loki
and sylvie if you think i'm evil just
wait until you meet my
variants you may hate the dictator but
something far worse is going to fill
that void if you depose
confirming that there were still other
kangs out there and indeed a new more
authoritarian kang comes to power after
he who remains is deposed however if you
rewind back to hewre main's backstory
before the conflict there was an era of
cooperation and at least one past
idealistic nathaniel richards with high
hopes for multiversal peace and order in
fact he who remains even lamented
hinting at his past trials and errors
before he eventually arrived at the tva
i've lived
a million lifetimes this is the only way
tva it works his tva works because he
remains knows from a past variant who
tried to make a perfect ideal of this
authority that a transparent oligarchic
version does not work the illuminati is
destined to fail and only a tva made
from the literal broken pieces of that
institution a dictatorship that cloaks
itself in endless layers of bureaucratic
red tape can get the job done now you
may be thinking
didn't loki happen before multiverse of
madness i mean that's the order it's all
gonna be on disney plus right well no no
no my friends the citadel at the end of
time and i suspect the illuminati hq as
well both of these exist outside the
normal linear flow of time so who knows
what caused what but to he remains all
of time is unfolding all at once so
everything he said to loki and sylvie
was steeped in the knowledge of what is
about to happen in multiverse madness
and i cannot wait to learn that this
dude found dr strange's broken watch in
a pile of rubble and decided to name it
miss minutes
if that nonsense didn't immediately make
you hate me you can follow me on
instagram and twitter at eavoss you can
follow new rockstars and subscribe to
new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thank you so much
for watching and uh by the way when it
comes to museums i love museums but uh
you know indiana jones line that belongs
at a museum
it really belongs where you found it so
uh let me pitch you on my indiana jones
spec script where short round follows
indy's dying wish to return all the
relics back to the temples where they
found them so we opened on a cambodian
temple 1971 hey hey where are you going
[Music]
you